- [Gary] Fuck.
You've got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
ONE37 dinner, all-star DRock
filming content for days.
♪ All my homies swooping
on the grass is day one ♪
♪ Oh my god look how I
kill 'em with skate puns ♪
♪ I get it popping like
I'm cooking up the bacon ♪
I get bored easily in this set up, so.
I literally just left our room,
just to walk to get action.
That's literally what just happened.
♪ Gets the candy in the jar way ♪
♪ And the lotto yeah I know ♪
♪ Guess we'll see how far it goes ♪
♪ Thank you for the compliment ♪
♪ Now baby please enjoy the show ♪
I'm going to say something
very interesting.
If you knew that as a 25 year old,
what he feels in his
heart and brain at 33,
what I feel at 43, and
what he feels at 50,
here's the punchline, we
all feel exactly the same.
If you knew that you were going
to live your whole life over again,
and you'll be his age, and you knew
that he basically has the same fire
right here and right here,
If I could get every 25 year old,
to know that they're not
even in the dressing room
putting on their shorts for the game yet,
and they think they're done.
- Yeah.
They're like, oh shit, I didn't
figure it out yet, right?
You know what Clue said
to me the other night?
He said, if you know
somebody, and you see them
do something bad to somebody else,
it's inevitable that they'll do it to you.
- [Man] Yeah of course, I
know what you're saying.
- I don't know, I've been thinking,
literally I'm being serious with you.
I'm bringing it up now,
I've been thinking about,
I've thought about it multiple
times every day since I saw you.
I know it, but I don't know
why the way you said it
clicked with me a little bit.
So my brother and I have a sports agency.
And Ryan and I are partners in this ONE37,
and every year at the
Super Bowl we're throwing
up the fuckin' event.
I don't know if you know this,
but we had YG come through--
- Like this last Super Bowl?
- Yeah, and we had Lil Keed,
the kid I just put you with,
and Tee Grizzley, and we fucking won it.
- Hey Gary V, I love you,
I appreciate you.
- I love you baby!
- You heard me?
- I fuckin' love you!
(upbeat music)
YG killed, YG is some performer, boy.
- Oh, he performed?
- The way I told my brother who's 11 years
younger than me to be an entrepreneur?
Was we would go to garage sales,
buy shit, come home, and flip on Ebay,
when Ebay was early, and make real money.
And then one of the top
50 all-time flips for us,
was we went somewhere, and they
had like 500 Jet magazines.
And we bought it for 10 bucks.
And when we took it home,
we started looking it up,
the Muhammad Ali, the Michael Jackson,
they were like 30 to 50 a piece.
- [Woman] Wow.
- We made like two, three
thousand on the 10 bucks.
- [Man] That's crazy.
- Jet magazine.
That's the shit I want to buy.
Like I would buy today Jet magazine,
and make it a web site
and make it hot again.
In 2008, I owned Rick Ross,
Young Jock, I owned every...
Drake.com, I owned everybody's .com.
I owned Kanye...
Guys, I at one time owned Kanyewest@.com.
- That was you buying
out the rapper websites.
- Yeah.
- We was looking for you.
(Dee laughs)
- But no,
- We was looking for this guy.
We was looking for him.
- You'll appreciate this!
You'll appreciate this!
Every time somebody hit
me up, I gave it to them.
I owned rickross.com,
I owned kanyewest.com,
I owned youngjock.com, I
owned fuckin' everything.
'Cause nobody knew.
I did in the wine business
like 10 year earlier,
like all the big wines
like Caymus, Silver Oak.
But I never wanted to do the wrong thing.
So, like literally Kanye's lawyer said,
"How much do you want for Kanye?"
And I literally, I replied in a minute,
zero, what's your IP address?
The reason you're going
to win, is you wouldn't
do something with something
you didn't believe in.
Thus, you're set.
But, the requirement is
to listen to other shit
to see what's serendipitously
hits you in the heart.
Because authentic artists fuck
with other authentic artists.
Tony Bennett and Lady Gaga worked
because they're the same person.
Now, it's about finding the
EDM, country, pop, K-pop.
You want to really take it...
You want to be an entrepreneur?
Listen to every K-pop
band, until you find one
you fuck with, you'll
make 50 million in Asia.
I keep telling people, I'm not telling you
to do some bullshit like Milli Vanilli.
I'm telling you to open
up your fuckin' mind,
listen to everything
that isn't in your genre,
and the first time you're
working out, vibing, smokin',
and you hear something
and you're like, oh, that?
That's who you do it with.
And then you fucking siphon audience.
Man, if I was in the same shit
that I'm doing with business,
if I actually had this talent,
I would 24 seven listen to K-pop,
find the first thing I fuck with,
and fly to South Korea and
go in the studio and produce,
and make a hundo in Asia the next year.
- I gotta split, there's
a thing I gotta get to.
- I love you
- How long you out here?
- I'm leaving Sunday, midday.
- I'm a be here till Monday morning too.
Maybe we'll link before
the end of this weekend.
- Drock, get this photo for me.
♪ Cause energy don't lie ♪
♪ Enemies won't fly ♪
♪ But best believe your inner peace ♪
♪ Electricity in their eye ♪
♪ And when you plan sweet victory ♪
♪ They want a piece of that pie ♪
You guys know about the fuckin' legend.
- Yeah man, NBA All-Star
week you know the vibe.
- Google it!
Do your fuckin' homework
if you don't know.
That's actually a good line.
- [Gary] We had to
pretty it up, real talk.
It froze for a minute.
Tomboy talent.
Great ONE37 party, great first
kick-off to NBA All-Star.
Gonna go back, get some sleep.
Sleeps important for the entrepreneurs.
Everybody's gonna go to the Jordan party.
I'm not going to Jordan
party, fuck Michael Jordan.
I'm a real Nick's fan, see ya.
♪ Our cash make it swish
like a three ball ♪
♪ Let my arm hang out let it free ball ♪
♪ And I got this on my
own I ain't need y'all ♪
♪ Always got to pay your
dues nothing free dog ♪
♪ I need power respect
on a nigga kneeing ♪
♪ I said all my dogs real ♪
♪ That's the only breeding, aye ♪
♪ We that total package in delivery ♪
♪ God open doors for us now got chivalry ♪
♪ Yeah, aye ♪
(shoes screeching)
(ball bouncing)
- [Male] (laughs) you all right?
(shoes screeching)
(ball bouncing)
- Is this yours?
- [Drock] Yeah.
- Did you post it yet?
- [Drock] No, I'm going
to post everything later.
What'd you just do? (laughs)
You posted on twitter.
- All right, let's run, let's go!
(Drock laughs)
- [Man] Are you out for the next one?
- Who are they gonna sub in
for Aces, that's the question.
You should get to decide--
- [Woman] Who decides, you
guys can't leave until you...
- [Man] I have no idea.
- It's not great, like--
- [Drock] Well you're standing up.
- No, definitely not broken,
but it's definitely not phenomenal.
- [Drock] Jesus...
Bro...
- Dude, it fuckin' hurts.
- [Gary] Fuck.
♪ Power respect on a nigga kneeing ♪
♪ I said all my dogs real ♪
♪ That's the only breeding, aye ♪
♪ We that total package in the delivery ♪
♪ God open doors for us
now that's chivalry, aye ♪
(light music)